as many watched the nights in person
some bars and resorts across the valley
were also filled with fans
this is the first weekend since the new
cdc mask
guidelines went into effect reporter
katie houston went to crimson at night
that was at red rock resort to see how
fans celebrated there
we knew it today was the first playoffs
game for the night so we thought what
better to do than go watch the nights
out at
night's theme bar kalina conner is one
of many that showed up to cheer on the
golden knights at the sold out crimson
at night pop-up at red rock resort
it's really fun like all of the decor
and everything with the dj
everything about it is super like
low-key but also
really energetic crimson at night is the
latest in the series of pop-ups at red
rock drawing in both locals and visitors
ryan muccio drove in from parum to watch
the game surrounded by knights fans
it's amazing that's what i missed from
before the fans make everything it makes
or breaking so
it's great not only are fans excited to
cheer on the nights but to do so with
less restrictions
and no masks this week the cdc eased
mask wearing guidelines for fully
vaccinated people
saying they don't have to wear masks
outdoors and in most indoor settings
muchia works in healthcare and is happy
to see some changes
it's been intense and so i'm fully
vaccinated so it's nice to be able to
sit here without a mask
and just enjoy and be with people again
connor is breathing a sigh of relief
saying it's refreshing to see people's
faces and smiles once again
everybody just feels like they can
breathe you know everyone can just take
a step back
really appreciate everything around them
and just have a good time
kate houston 8 news now